اكد زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه يا اير
لابيد ان ما يهتم به فقط هو اعاده
المخطوفين في غزه وعقب لقائه مع رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو قال
لابيد انه مستعد للعمل معه من اجل استعاده
المخطوفين سواء كان داخل الحكومه او
خارجها قلت لرئيس الحكومه لا يهمني
الحقائب الوزاريه فانا كنت رئيسا للوزراء
ما يعنيني شيء واحد فقط ان نعيد المخطوفين
واذا احتاج مني شبكه حمايه باي مجال من
داخل الحكومه او خارجها فما عليه الا ان
يبلغني وكان لابيت قد قال ان اسرائيل تسير
نحو كارثه اخرى وان السماح لوزير الامن
القومي تمار بن كفير باداره الاحداث في
شهر رمضان في المسجد الاقصى والقدس سيؤدي
الى اشتعال المنطقه ودع لبيد رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو لتجريد بن كفير من
صلاحياته تشكيل فريق يكون قادرا على اعداد
اسرائيل لشهر
رمضان من واجب تحذير الحكومه فالدوله غير
مستعده لرمضان ولا توجد خطه ولم تجرى
مناقشات عملياته وسياسيه على نحو جيد ونحن
في الطريق الى كارثه اخرى في وقت يكون فيه
بن غفير المسؤول عن جبل الهيكل والقدس على
رئيس الوزراء ان يجرده من صلاحياته
والتاكد من ان الشرطه وشرطه حرس الحدود
يقومون بواجباتهم بمسؤوليه ويهدئ الوضع
بدلا من اشعاله لم نكن بحاجه الى الحوار
في وول ستريت جورنال ولنتذكر ان بن غفير
مهرج وانه يفضل اشعال الحرائق بدل
اطفائها